the 32-year-old veteran left-hander drew
smiley coming off a win last time around
sunday at miami
and a quick strikeout recorded by smiley
two gone
three balls meanwhile to paul
goldschmidt sharply hit right at the
shortstop dance b
swanson and a sharp opening ending for
drew smiley in the nightcap half-ending
gone
the 32-year-old veteran left-hander
kwang yoon kim
1-4 on the year and he missed with ball
four
lacuna board to start the home first and
that'll bring up the reigning national
league mvp
freddie freeman who was one for three in
the opener in a fly ball
out to center field for dylan carlson
and that's the first down for kim
tonight
ballin two strikes to count to austin
riley
on the ground for sosa who's busy this
sending nothing comes to the lead-off
walk
here's a full count pitch home to o'neal
and he loses him on ball four first
cardinal base runner in game two
he's had to work really hard to get
through innings this year
quick out here on sosa as there are two
away
and the one pitch squibbed off the end
of the bat to a diving stop by freeman
gets up
runs to the bag what a play freddie
freeman takes a base hit away from paul
deyoung he squibbed it right off the end
of the bat
i'm sure it had a lot of spin on it but
freddie diving to his right made a nice
pick up
and then outran deyoung for the third
and final out no runs no hits one walk
one left we go to the bottom half of the
second
swanson almante and heredia here in the
second
two one to swanson is passed aronado
into left field
nolan a little slow to get to his feet
after laying out to try to make that
play
past the renato dives to his left and if
that man can't catch it with eight gold
gloves
not many well can't be caught oh and two
the count to almonte who struck out
twice
in a hitless opener and he has struck
out in his first played appearance
tonight
one-two pitch is a fast ball away that's
hit right to paul goldschmidt at first
nothing comes to the lead-off single
here's the 2-0 pitch on the way to acuna
he hits one hard deep left field
this one taking flight back there
towards the wall
homer number 100 ronaldo cunha just
scorched one over the left field wall
and it's his 100th career home run
and he touches them all to make it
one-nothing atlanta here in the bottom
of the third
and alby's off the end of the bat pops
it up
[Applause]
sosa at the cutout
2-2 another fastball arenado lines it
right to riley who doubles it up for out
number two
a one to sosa hit in the air to right
field coming in as a cunha going out as
freeman this is all ronaldo cunha
and he has got it for round number three
easy little pop out
pitch on the way to riley round ball out
to third
this will be aronado's turn he sends one
across and it skips away
safe at first base is riley
round ball left side taken by arnotto
goes to second to soso social to
goldschmidt
double play now's a slick turn down
there at second base
and that goes five four three to shut
down the braves
2-2 breaking ball swung on it missed and
that's four
strikeouts for smiley in the midst of
his best start of the year
78 mile an hour breaking ball here by
smiling his best one
and it stays in the outer third
wanna pitch it high in the air to right
ronald acuna looking up into the blue
sky
a few steps to his right opens the glove
has out number two
in the air to shallow center field
and another one two three inning for
drew smiley
guillermo already leads things off
against ryan helsley who is the new
pitcher on the mount for the cardinals
he starts with a strikeout
and there's one gone
one two chasing and missing smith skips
a few feet away from kisner picks it up
and lobster the inside of the bag and
goldsmith secures the strikeout
payoff pitch to him past the pitcher
sosa has trouble getting it out of his
glove and smiley beats it out
we talked about the good fastball the
could curve on now the wheels
and the contact mattie eight straight
four-seam fastballs by housley
and he locks him up on a ninth straight
a big strikeout with a man on to keep it
a one-run game
to smiley back to work having not
allowed a hit tonight
but the cardinals offense has not made a
lot of noise
late in games boy riley has been superb
tonight
did he check it on the appeal he did not
fifth strike out of the game for bruce
smiley
in the fifth strikeout on the curveball
and his best one of the night sharp and
tight
so his longest career no hit bid
continues
now through five and two thirds here's
goldschmidt
on the ground for all these tough plays
spins throws not in time
likely to be scored a base hit ending
smiley's no hit bid
that's going to be all for the starter a
great night from bruce smiley braves to
the bullpen
reilly knocks that one down nobody has a
play
and it'll be a hard hit infield single
for arenado
tyler o'neill now with the tying and go
ahead runs on base
the stretch the pitch swung on missed
he struck him out luke jackson with a
big
k and the cardinals strand the pair
swinging a miss he struck him out came
up and in with a heater
2-2 and riley swings and misses takes a
hard bounce off the backstop kisner's
throw to first
in time to get riley by a half a step
[Applause]
now saint louis is down to their last
strike will smith
cuts it loose sword guy missed he struck
him out of the braves have beaten the
cardinals
beautifully pitched one to nothing win
for atlanta
earns a split of the doubleheader today